[Music]
season six of Game of Thrones lives on
in our hearts but there are a few
characters that have long left the world
of the living
deaths are a huge part the Game of
Thrones experience some are expected
while some are not some ringers pain
while others bring us a kind of morbid
joy but over six seasons HBO sure have
got good at them these are the six best
deaths of Game of Thrones Season six
Episode one kicked off with a pretty
heavy death after the coup of dawn the
murder of Doran Martell and the
assassination of princess Marcella in
season five the sand snakes abara and I
Marius and ambushed the prints on his
barge as he busies himself painting some
pebbles while he gets to choose how he
dies he should have kept his wits about
him because unfortunately he's the first
gruesome death the season the tip of Oba
Haris spear exploding from the young
prince's face as he turns to face
Nymeria left to bleed on the floor as
the sisters swap their awkward banter on
the way out you're a greedy [ __ ] you
know that
we've been hoping these two traitors
bite the bullet ever since they muttered
as they plunge their knives deep into
our beloved John Snow well I'm sure they
didn't expect the young Lord Commander
to rise from the dead and hold them
accountable for their crimes that little
[ __ ] Olli thorn and the other traitors
are seen new stand ready to be hung by
the neck until dead now this may not be
that gruesome but you've got to hand it
to the makeup department for their
depiction of hanged man truly unsettling
out of all the deaths on this list this
is probably the one that was most
intense after learning of Hodos old self
before he became the simple giant that
Shepherds bran threw the unwelcome North
he suddenly snatched away from us during
his final noble deed saving bran from
one of his many bloody screw-ups
Hodor takes scratches and bites and
holds back a wave of the night Kings
undead army but he did his job he held
that door and now he holds our hearts
the Lord of the most northern house of
Westeros was adamant that he loved to
fight wildlings he's been doing it all
his life well if that's the case then
maybe he should have learned not to let
his guard down during the battle the
bastards it wasn't looking good to
Tommen even taking a few head butts once
the Warriors have become squashed
together but as soon as small Jon looks
towards the arriving Knights of the Vale
he gets a big old chunk bitten out his
throat then again I'm sure wildlings
have even worse Walder Frey was a
disgusting man so it's only right that
his last meal was as foul as he was
we've seen people get their throat cut
on the show before sure but we've never
seen a gross old man he a pie made from
the flesh of his two sons the mixture of
him slowly realizing the ingredients of
his pie the panic on his face as he
knows he's about to die and the look of
Glee on iies face as he bleeds out all
over himself and his dinner made many
viewers wince on the other hand he's a
horrible old codger who made the red
wedding happen so to hell with him
Ramsey's death was what we wanted for a
long time he's been the target of much
fan hatred and deservedly so of all the
evil characters are of all their evil
acts I think he's definitely top of the
rankings from chopping up sausage and
feeding newborn babies to dogs to
slaying anyone in his path this
despicable warden of the North seemed
untouchable and ultimately vile so
there's no surprise that each punch Jon
Snow delivered to that smug bastards
face fell
oh so good to watch and the beautiful
horrifying irony of having his own
bloodthirsty hounds rip him apart just
as he's done to so many others was
brutally satisfying I think we all felt
like Sansa in that moment it was tough
to watch but we just couldn't look away
so those are my picks for the six best
deaths of season six if you've got any
you think deserved a place on this list
then let us know in the comment section
below or tweet me at a regular Dave for
more Game of Thrones features make sure
you subscribe to GameSpot
[Music]